filipino health workers are some of the
most sought after in the world
but in their home country many say the
government has treated them poorly and
they lack some of the basic benefits and
protection
it is sad that many of us have died many
of us become sick and many have resigned
or opted to retire early nurses in the
philippines get a monthly salary of
about three hundred dollars and doctors
around six hundred critics argue that
too little compared to the funds that
government has available
funds that are alleged to have been
misappropriated during the government's
awarding of multi-million dollar
contracts in its pandemic response
from a zero declared income in 2019
how could family a trading corporation
with no sufficient capital without a
track record because it was only
incorporated in september 2019
back
8.68 billion
worth of government contracts what kind
of due diligence the contract the
senator's referring to was awarded by
the department of budget and management
and that's now facing a probe in the
senate senators are also asking why the
government agency awarded contracts to a
company whose officers are facing
allegations of fraud embezzlement and
stock manipulation in taiwan or did
somebody introduce you to the official
sub-family
president rodrigo duterte is also
alleged to have been involved duterte
directly controls the budget office
and in this video he's seen meeting
formerly executives in 2017 together
with the chinese national michael yang
michael young was duterte's economic
advisor according to a philippines
intelligence agency report he was
involved in importing illegal drugs in
duterte's hometown davao city
duterte who once said he would not
tolerate even a whiff of corruption in
his government has defended his actions
we are inviting investors
that's why i went to china several times
to ask them to help us aids close to
president duterte and even members of
his family have long faced claims of
corruption but critics say reports of
scandals and embezzlement at a time when
millions of filipinos are going hungry
and health workers are struggling during
a pandemic have put president rodrigo
duterte's credibility at an all-time low
jamal allendogen al jazeera manila